[موسيقى]
مساء الخير قمه بريكسي حديث الساعه تتجه
انظار العالم الى جوهانسبرج عاصمه جنوب
افريقيا التي تستضيف القمه 15 للمجموعه
بدايه من الغد الموافق 22 اغسطس ولمده
ثلاثه ايام اسباب الاهتمام كثيره لكن على
راسها البت في عضويه دول جديده ترغب في
الانضمام لتكتل بريكس دول مثل من 42 دوله
من بينهم تمن دول عربيه يبدو اهتمامهم ومن
الاتنين دوله تقدمت 22 دوله بطلبات رسميه
للانضمام من هذه الدول السعوديه
واندونيسيا والجزائر وايران والارجنتين
ومصر والامارات وبنكلاديش والبحرين لكن
دول بريكس الخمسه منقسمون حول هذه القضيه
اذ تتحمس الصين وروسيا لتوسيع المجموعه
باضافه اعضاء جدد فيما تتحفظ البرازيل
والهند فلماذا قبل الاجابه على هذا السؤال
اذكركم ما هو بريكس ولماذا تتحمس دول
كثيره حول العالم للانضمام اليه
هو نادي او تكتل سياسي مكونا في الوقت
الحالي من خمسه اعضاء اساسيه هي الصين
وروسيا والبرازيل والهند وجنوب افريقيا
اسم بريكس مشتق من الحروف الاولى لاسماء
هذه الدول الخمسه باللغه الانجليزيه من
ابتكر اسم المجموعه على هذا النحو هو
الاقتصاد
البريطانيل في 2001 عندما كان يعمل في بنك
جولد من وقتها كان جيمي يشير ببساطه الى
اربعه دول ناميه تحقق معدلات نمو متسارعه
وان هذا النمو يمثل فرصه للمستثمرين
الخائفين من الاستثمار في الاسواق
المتقدمه مثل الولايات المتحده واوروبا
بعد هجمات 11 سبتمبر في هذا العام هذه
الدول التي اشار اليها جيم اونيل وقتها هي
البرازيل وروسيا والهند والصين ولم يشهر
وقتها الى جنوب افريقيا واطلق على هذه
الدول اختصارا بريك اي الحرف الاول من
اسماء هذه الدول الاربعه
يعني جيم كان يفكر في هذه الدول الاربعه
باعتبارها فئه استثماريه وليست ناديا
سياسيا كما تحولت لاحقا راقت الفكره للدول
الاربعه ادراكا منهم ان نموههم السريع في
ذلك الوقت يعني ان لديهم مصالح وتحديات
مشتركه مواقف هذه الدول الاربعه بالاساس
كانت قريبه داخل منظمه التجاره العالميه
لكنهم ايقنوا ان تاثيرهم في النظام
العالمي الذي تهيمن عليه الولايات المتحده
سيكون اكبر اذا وحدوا اصواتهم وبالفعل
نظمت روسيا الاجتماع الاول لوزراء خارجيه
الدول بريك على هامش الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده في 2006 وعقدت المجموعه اول قمه
لها على مستوى الرؤساء في 2009
ودعت الدول الاربعه جنوب افريقيا للانضمام
الى المجموعه في نهايه 2010 ليكون
لافريقيا ممثلا في هذه المجموعه واصبحت
المجموعه بريكس بعد اضافه اول حرف من
العضو الجديد وهي جنوب افريقيا او ثوبه
افريقيا باللغه الانجليزيه
روسيا طبعا هي اكبر مصدر للنفط وثاني اكبر
مصدر للغاز الطبيعي اما الهند والصين
فيلعبان دورا جوهريا في التحول الى الطاقه
النظيفه لان لهما نصيب كبير جدا في تطوير
تكنولوجيات الطاقه النظيفه الطاقه النظيفه
زي ايه زي طاقه الرياح والشمس والهيدروجين
الاخضر الى اخره اذا هو السبب الاول السبب
الثاني ان المجموعه بتقدم نفسها بديلا
للنظام العالمي الحالي الذي تقوده
الولايات المتحده وكثير من الدول المهتمه
بالانضمام الى بريكس اما انها فريضه هذا
النظام او مغضوب عليها من الولايات
المتحده وتبحث لها عن ملاذم اخر ابرز مثال
على هذا النوع من الدول الراغبه في
الانضمام الى ايران لكن في دول اخرى ليست
فريضه النظام الحالي ولكنها متضرره من
وضاقت ذرعا بهيمنه الولايات المتحده
ومؤسساتها
لاساءت اداره العالم وبالتالي فهي تدعم اي
تحالف يمكن ان يحقق التوازن في هذا العالم
ولهذه الفئه بتنتمي معظم الدول الناشئه
الراغبه في الانضمام الى
دول الخليج على سبيل المثال هم اصدقائهم
بل وحلفاء للولايات المتحده لكنهم يرغبون
في توزيع اوراقهم بعد ان قضوا عشرات
السنوات في الاعتماد على امريكا وحدها اما
السبب الثالث وعنصر الجذب المباشر لكثير
من دول العالم فهو ببساطه الرغبه في
الاستفاده من بنك التنميه الجديد وما هو
بنك التنميه الجديد والبنك الذي انشاته
دول في 2014
وهدفه تمويل مشروعات البنيه التحتيه في
الاقتصادات الناشئه منح هذا البنك اللي
بيبلغ راس ماله المصدر مئه مليار دولار
قرودا بحوالي 33 مليار دولار امريكي لاكثر
من 96 مشروعا داخل الدول الخمسه ده طبعا
منذ تاسيسه والكلام ده على عهده الموقع
الرسمي للبنك بالمناسبه للبنك نظام عضويه
منفصل منفصل عن تكتل بريكس لانه قبل
العضويات دول جديده من خارج بريكس دول مثل
بنجلاديش والامارات ومصر وهناك دول اخرى
بتسعى للانضمام الى البنك رغم انها ليست
اعضاء في بريكس لكن قطعا استفاده هذه
الدول من البنك ستكون اكثر اذا تمتعوا
بالعضويه الدائمه في المجموعه البنك
باختصار بيسعى للاعب بدور موازي ومنافس
للبنك الدولي وتقدر تقول كمان صندوق النقد
لكن هو اكتر ليه البنك الدولي اللي بيمول
مشروعات البنيه التحتيه
وبديه ان راس ماله الحالي اللي هو 100
مليار دولار لا يكفي ليحل محل البنك
الدولي وصندوق النقد لكن توسيع العضويه
يعني زياده القدره على رفع راس المال ما
هي كل دوله هتنضم الى البنك هتشارك في راس
مال البنك وبالتالي سوف تزيد قدرته على
منفسه منافسه المؤسسات الغربيه وفقا لاحدى
الدراسات بحلول منتصف العام 2030 اي خلال
حوالي سبع سنوات تقريبا يمكن ان تصل قدره
البنك على الاقراض الى حوالي 350 مليار
دولار امريكي ما يعني تجاوز البنك الدولي
بايجاد شديد الدول الراغبه في الانضمام
تامل في توسيع نفوذها الدبلوماسي
والنفاذ الى فرص تجاريه واستثماريه مربحه
نعود الى سؤال الحلقه لماذا تتردد دول
المجموعه في فتح الباب لاعضاء الجدد السبب
هو الخلاف بين اعضاء المجموعه فقد اعلنت
المجموعه عن فتح باب الع ضويه لاول مره
العام الماضي اي في 2022 بضغط من الصين
ومدعومه من روسيا مع عدم ممانعه من جنوب
افريقيا في مقابل تحفظ وتردد من جانب
الهند والبرازيل ولكل اسبابه ترى الصين في
زياده عدد الاعضاء خصوصا الدول الناميه
المؤثره حول العالم دعما لنفوذها وخطوه
اساسيه لتحقيق طموحها في بناء نظام عالمي
جديد تقوده هي في نهايه المطاف وهي ما
بتقولش كده طبعا بس ده اللي ممكن يتم
استنتاجه ببساطه وترى روسيا في زياده
العدد فرصه لتقويد هيمنه الولايات المتحده
وبناء عالم جديد متعدد الاقطاب فضلا عن ان
زياده التجاره مع الاعضاء الجدد سوف يقلل
يقينا من تاثير العقوبات الغربيه على
اقتصادها الفرق بين الصين وروسيا ليس فقط
في الدوافع المختلفه قليلا ولكن ايضا في
درجه الحماس فالصين بالغه الحماس اما
روسيا فحماسها اقل قليلا لزياده اعضاء
المجموعه موقفها باختصار نفضل توسيع
العضويه في بريكس لكن لن نقاتل من اجله مش
هنفتعل المعركه مع الهند والبرازيل موقف
الهند والبرازيل مختلف كلاهما باختصار
يخشى من تراجع نفوذهبا داخل المجموعه في
حال فتحت الابواب لاعضاء جدد طبيعي صوتك
داخل تكتل من خمس دول ليس مثل صوتك في
تكتل من خمسين دوله كلما زاد العدد من
وجهه نظرهم قل نفوذهم وزاد نفوذ الصين
هذا الخوف طبعا بيعكس قناعه الدولتين ان
معظم الاعضاء الجدد حريص على الانضمام
طمعا في علاقات اقوى مع الصين بالدرجه
الاولى التي يمثل اقتصادها وحدها ضعفي
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لكل دول بريكس
الاربعه مجتمعين الاخرين يعني يعني اقتصاد
الصين الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للصين ضعفي
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للدول الاربعه
الاخرى في بريكس
لكن الخوف من تراجع النفوذ داخل بريكس ليس
هو السبب الوحيد
لكل منهما لكل من الهند والبرازيل سبب
اضافي مختلف اكبر مخاوف الهند فيما يتعلق
بالعبوات الجديده وان تصبح مجموعه تتمحور
حول الصين الهند والصين بينهما خلافات
كثيره
استاذنكم ان تعودوا لحلقه سابقه بعنوان
اسباب الصراع المكتوم بين عملاقي اسيا لكن
ابرز هذه الخلافات ببساطه هو طبعا خلاف
الحدود من الستينات وبيندلع من وقت لاخر
واندلع مؤخرا وهناك توتر في العلاقه بين
الدولتين
الهند ترى انه اذا كان ولابد من توسيع
العضويه فلا يجب ان تسمح بدول سوف تكون
يقينا تحت نفوذ الصين ما يجعل المجموعه
ناديا صينيا وتكون الهند بذلك قد ساعدت في
تعظيم النفو الصيني وهو ما لا تتمناه
ووفقا لمسؤولين امريكان وهنود مطلعين على
كواليس المفاوضات بين الدول الخمس في
المباحثات التمهيديه قبل قمه جوهانسبرج
وهؤلاء المسؤولين تحدثوا الى موقع المعروف
فان الهند تريد تحديد قواعد ومعايير اوضح
لقبول اعضاء قبل فتح باب العضويه وتفضل ان
تتوجه المجموعه لضم دول ديمقراطيه مثل
الارجنتين ونيجيريا والهدف الخفي بين
قوسين ان هذه الدول اللي هي ده كان انظمه
ديمقراطيه سوف تكون على الارجح اكثر ميلا
للهند الديمقراطيه عن الصين ذات النظام
الشمولي
اما البرازيل فهي لا تريد استعداء امريكا
ولا الاتحاد الاوروبي وتخشى من ان تحول
الصين المشغوله بصراعها مع امريكا
المجموعه لجبهه مناوئه للغرب
وتكتل بديل لمجموعه السبعه اللي بتقودها
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها او نواه لنظام
عالمي جديد تقوده الصين البرازيل حريصه
على بقاء الوضع الراهن النظام العالمي
الراهن مع اصلاحه وليس هدمه وتقترح بدلا
من فتح باب العضويه الدائمه انشاء فئتين
جديدتين فئه مراقب وهي موجوده بالفعل وفئه
دوله شريكه على ان يتحرك الاعداء الجدد من
خلال هاتين الفئتين قبل النظر في ترقيه
هذه الدول الى وضع العضو الدائم ووفقا
لبعض المسؤولين فان البرازيل تدعم
اندونيسيا مبدئيا لتكون اول دوله تن ضم
الى هذا التكتل تكتل بريكس
ملاحظتان اذا تمكنت دول المجموعه من تجاوز
هذا الخلاف وايجاد حلا وسطا وهو خلاف ليس
سهلا يعني فان هذا سيعظم من اهميه نادي
بريكس ويمهد الطريق لتجاوز تحديات كثيره
جدا تهدد استمراره اما اذا فشلوا فان ذلك
سيضعف من نفوذ النادي وقد يزرع بذور خلاف
قد يقضي على المجموعه من اساسها وهذه قصه
اخرى تستحق ان نناقشها في حلقه مقبله
بريكس قد يصاب بالشلل وقد يصاب بالدمور
اذكركم ان مجموعه بريكس رغم جاذبيتها
واهميتها بتعاني من تحديات ضخمه جدا كي
تستمر المجموعه اللي كانت واعيده اقتصاديا
مثلا من عشرين سنه
واقترحها جيم ونيل لتكون فئه استثماريه
مغريه للمستثمرين تعاني الان من متاعب
اقتصاديه كبيره
فباستثناء الهند كان اداء دول البريكس اقل
من نظرائها في الاسواق الناشئه من حيث
معدلات النمو
على مدى السنوات الخمس الماضيه العقوبات
الغربيه حولت روسيا لبلد غير قبل
للاستثمار فيه من كثير من الدول على الاقل
ونفس العقوبات جعلت الصين نسبيا اقل
جاذبيه للمستثمرين الاجانب وتباطى
الاقتصاد البرازيلي بشكل ملحوظ في السنوات
الاخيره وتعاني جنوب افريقيا من نقص مزمن
في الكهرباء بيشل او بيؤثر على معدلات
الاستثمار المحليه والخارجيه في هذه
الدوله وحتى الهند باتت مهدده باضطرابات
طائفيه ودينيه لكن التحدي الاخطر طبعا هو
الصراع الهند الصيني فضلا عن الضغوط
الغربيه اللي بتسعى لافشال هذه المجموعه
التي تقلق الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
الملحوظه الثانيه ان النظر في اصدار عمله
موحده لمجموعه بريكس كلام يطرح في وسائل
الاعلام خصوصا الاعلام غير الجاد لكنه لا
يحظى